oh my god this is tim schafer's here
hello hello how you doing having me nice
to be welcome back to the show yeah and
I'm excited to see your shirt wearing
torn because I was looking forward to
seeing that other shirt don't assure
that i always wear all the time i said
i'm not having to my conor mcgregor sure
exactly what UFC I wish I but I can I
didn't if I thought you were right yeah
totally knows you talked about with the
thing he's the good guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah I wore my good side lancashire too
cuz I saw that you guys photoshop so I'm
hoping you can Photoshop on EKG lose
live no you're drawing real before
exhibit posed to put that group that
cool thing you guys I'm wearing this
green shirt but we only have the
technology to project it onto one person
at any one time no night this is why I'm
wearing that I don't even know where
that I've seen that shirt on the
internet yeah I don't think you guys get
any money she is no I don't think it's
official so knowing that way in that way
I'm not breaking any any any laws I'm
good yeah definitely yeah thank you hey
Griffin not gonna came out today I know
watching again reloads later 15 15 years
later pillows everything every day makes
me feel old just walking makes me feel
old this makes me feel young again
because it's like 1998 all over again
where you guys born in 1998 yeah i was i
was 12 i was in high school okay so i
was born in 72 so i was like wow he's
six when i first played nice good
fandango sauna i am pretty old I didn't
even have peers yeah oh we didn't have
to wow thanks for making your pubes well
it's just a Tim took one off your top
shine right before we start reading
television talk about them people missed
the great day where tim schafer tweaked
my neck there was a cat hair right here
and i wasn't this is getting into like
the greg miller territory where ya
claims let's just not getting I'll never
wash this nipple again let's talk about
video games playstation 4 playstation
vita vita and of course on the mac and
linux yeah
who do you thinks gonna buy grim
fandango in 2050 do you think it's gonna
be like predominantly folks come back
and play it gallatin see first of all
skeletons yeah pretty much everyone has
a skeleton so it's pretty much Barry
they're just so excited for positive
portrayals of skeletons and video game
time everyone joins Kelly under zombies
in the blood so we have a game with dead
people who are friendly and nice yes
tell us about the what you've kind of
done new to bring grim fandango to the
available to the PC because what I find
funny about it is the grim and swat 4
are the two old pc games that i was
never able to get running on modern like
windows yeah like they just were they
disappeared it was it like a muscle to
play those games via we relied on like
the fan community because they have kept
it going with things like residual via
Morgan and and even fix some bugs and so
we actually gathered a lot of that
knowledge we fixed a lot of there's an
old bug we're like a major section the
plot was never explained occasional game
and we're like let's fix that so that
makes sense to people and for everyone
oh you've got my new Griffin [ __ ] tattoo
wait huh oh my god and you got my
girlfriend I go neck tattoo it's weird
that someone is moving that I don't
believe it no regrets hi mom right on
the glottis from a tie rod is very yes
way to go miss wearing kids is really
great yeah yeah the cop Chris looks good
I won't move the rest of the time dad
yeah you got an orchestra involved as
well yeah I mean first got to dig up all
the old stuff and find it and make it
run again and I was exciting and we got
a bit like a tub of tapes from lucasarts
they still had the archive or I found
like these format of tapes that we had
to like find a guy who collected old
scuzzy drive to decode these and we
found the original like Pro Tools audio
sessions so we were able Oh Peter
McConnell the composer he had done you
know a symphonic score but he used some
digital parts and some live musician but
he was able to replace the digital parts
in the symphony with actual symphony in
melbourne australia the Melbourne
Symphony Orchestra require I was like it
was gave me chills like I watched the
the video of them playing I've never
heard that score played by a live
orchestra before as I go
this sounds amazing so remastered the
orchestral store and some of the live
like jazz parts Peter play the guitar
and Exxon and then um we repainted all
the not me we I do it but we people I
know repainted own character didn't do
any work to as what makes it around so
it's hard to like the faster faster work
faster that's mostly wit but I do yes it
gets your shoulder risk is tired a lot
of struggle among my someone's got to do
it so we repainted all the character
textures to be all nice and high res and
look good and they actually did actual
dynamic lighting on the characters we've
never had before was like a flat kind of
lighting well so now I'm like man he
likes a cigarette in his face lights up
and and then we did hours of developer
commentary so this talking hearing me
talking that was not enough for you you
can hear more of it when you're playing
the game the commentary is a great
little touch because one of the ways I
love going back to play all the valve
games was in like portal and the entire
half I say was going through and to do
those developer commentaries who's
involved in that is it just yourself or
did you know folks a little um all the
team that had was still an area as I old
team reunion in different groups we had
a group of like the artists came
together and a bunch of like eight of
them sat together a room and talked
about making the art we had musicians
come in we had the audio team come in we
had the voice director dar o Farrell and
and talk about like both kind of
remembering like I remember that it was
it was interesting because we'd never
really had a chance to as a team kind of
celebrate the game because we made it
and it was it was really hot like a big
crunch mode and we're all so tired and
naturally afterwards I just kind of like
stumbled out of the buildings like where
am I like went home and took a vacation
and so it was kind of a nice to just get
together and talk about the game and now
that all the hard feelings are gone from
all that part late nights in crunch mode
yeah it just took 15 years videos them
to forgive you finally be like hey for
you forgive me mm is that a second
playthrough experience the developer
commentary or like cuz I've never played
grim fandango I'm super excited to play
it we know this value yeah I keep a list
you recommend that to be like a second
go-around or is
when it will at summer's play when it's
interesting cuz it like it's it's
triggered by you point electric or so
you don't have to hear it like it just
intrude on top of the dialog leave you
choose to listen to it when you're ready
for it so you could play turned on if
they go into the options and turn it on
we default to it off because that kind
of feeling of like what's let you play
once before you um you hear all me yes
not you guys aren't dropping chris
spoilers on that there oh maybe wouldn't
remain i hear this an achievement in
there for tank controls uh yes that was
your idea yeah and it's not called tanks
for the memories which is what some
people okay identical what's it actually
call the right way oh there was some
controversy about the UM oh my shirt is
still it's really they're really bad
work there was some controversy about
the original it's funny likes playing
this to young folks such as yourself hmm
but like my mom often says when we find
pictures of her and polyester striped
pants she's like they're very popular at
the time like dang controls they'd the
air where we did that 98 it was like a
tomb raider resonate only yes one wasn't
it wasn't evil like alone the dark i
think the first alone the door yeah
we're so excited about 3d but we didn't
know how to do it and then also in like
mario 64 comes that were like oh oh i
think between the direction you want to
go yeah and it works that's crazy who
would have thought of that the tank
controls let you because a lot of brim
was inspired by this game bio-forge
which was oh my garbage in game you play
that yes yeah you sing grow up guys hit
a leg off and you hit him with a laser
loose a grim fandango was inspired by
bio-forge not in a story but in the
technical execution is pre-rendered
backgrounds yeah okay and there's live
3d characters rendered on the fly in
front of ya hundred backwards with the
z-buffer that we saw that we're like oh
that's an interesting way to do 3d
adventure games so once it has to be so
shocked because I completed bio-forge
last night outside last night i
completed bio-forge last year or maybe
the year before wait you put it our
friends over at Giant Bomb for some
reason wanted to do a playthrough others
well I on that game is a real piece of
hot garbage when you play it now
I don't know okay I remember being
really interesting in terms of like your
identity changing based on your actions
like that but ok so when I was playing
this is a scene where you're running
down a hallway and you just press
forward right yeah but the camera cuts
low and it cuts above and it cuts to the
side is like oh so dramatic but you
don't have to worry about which
direction you're pressing the controller
with these chemicals and so that seemed
cool and that's why we did it but we
have some I don't want to call them
regrets but revaluations the past in
which decisions are regretted yes that
is a writer regretted yes that's not
resection yeah we see now that we should
have given some more options with so the
new master has both point-and-click
controls which you know there was no
reason actual um Tobias where the UH was
partly like the fanny that's a hack he's
Wow he put in these and so we contacted
them and we actually had him helpless he
was nice looks like a donate this is
worky dented to the point click control
so we did point click controls is an
option is that touch controls on the
Vita and tap yeah oh so you can do kind
of a combo you can come sweep nice play
with all yeah and also just regular you
know modern third person pushing a
character in the direction you want to
go inside the code for girlfriend it was
called like Mario versa to raid oh
really yeah excellent yeah oh that's the
end that's so that's how we brought it
up back in to make it not painful for
modern organ playing I have it be
actually fun so it's it's it's great
that you guys kind of manage to get
around or work with Lucas to to make
that happen when we're going to see her
work work wasn't work with you can't
actually you can't just sneak in and
steal your evil doors are not locked i
don't think that legally protects you
from sneaking in and stealing tapes from
somebody didn't they true it wasn't
there like a full throttle to that was
shown it like III oh yeah like 10 years
ago something started it that was
cancelled your yeah about the das do you
know how far my gosh there was a 3d guy
running around but I was working on it
yeah yeah you were infos like automatic
I'm torn about how I feel about that
I've ever I've ever thought about
picking up license up and given the
shake now that you've kind of a shake I
yeah well monkeys been re-mastered like
not all of them what the first too late
long as everyone buys three copies of
grandma I'm sure we'll be able to you're
good yeah we're good for we'll take it
we were doing data tentacle yeah okay
yeah that's not that's gonna be so three
copies of Graham three copies at a
tentacle and then I think per set and
then we'll get our bio-forge and then
I'm gonna yeah we're gonna get like
three master bio-forge call of origin
and it didn't they actually had a sequel
for that originally was going to be a
death match game there's a trailer brush
with making sure that I really probably
yeah looks like a little piece of hot
garbage rolls I love the fact that you
guys have the dev commentary on us as
something else you guys have been doing
or double fine productions you're sort
of video crew has been the Deb's plays
serious i gotta watch the Romero play
some doom yeah how long are you guys
going to keep doing these like where the
idea for this come because it seems like
you guys are doing like coverage of old
games yeah while you're making games
yeah I mean two player productions you
know the documentary crew that does the
Double Fine adventure or Kickstarter
broken age's documentary they they had
this idea of just like you know doing
you know let's plays but have the people
who actually made the games or people
who just have some interesting angle on
a game come in and play it and we had
you know the people who might Micah and
Yvonne who made the gauntlet des that
never came out played that you know and
seeing Brandon who's on your wall over
there yeah and in hackers el de carte
did you see Glee carved out of zelda
card to put an extra chip in it oh no
gave you a special sword and let you
play through all of Zelda without a
sword so if it's been fun and my one of
my favorites i think is um Donna's
coming out today which is we had a
speedrunner come in who plays SPEA
haven't he did a speedrun of psychonauts
tortoises like to i had the whole team
of psychonauts that still works at the
studio yeah watching him play and at
first it was like tearjerker he's
skipping everything that we did like
anime I guess my hair my scenes coming
up oh it's gone and best jumps over a
wall yeah you flying he's like did you
know the character you know he's just
doing all these crazy things and we're
horrified by the end of her we were like
this is amazing because watching like
watching someone do acrobatics and an
amazing stunts like he just has a
certain way of hitting pop the exact
right end of this thing to fly
the level and it was like a whole
different way to look at the game and
yeah even though a speedrunner is
essentially trying to break the way the
game designer wants that gave me playing
it still is like this deep love they
must have for the game because they've
dedicated countless hours to it right
yeah I mean like like I was saying it
feels like when you um we eat a
drumstick and then yeah someone is like
you didn't get all meat off that here
give that to me they find more meat on
this super old game the different way to
enjoy it and and yeah they have a
different other things you think are the
entertainment for them they're they're
trying to bypass and get around her like
I just put this amazing scene for you
and you're like skip pass I flew over
that level you designed that I love it
yeah what's 2015 then got four for you
guys obviously broken age the second act
of that will be out yeah q2 spring love
Liam springtime like the flowers the
butterflies I can age no we're just
wrapping it up we just had our like the
dialogues all done we're doing final
recording and pushing that stuff into
polish and that's going to be exciting
because I kicked off you know a while
back with that yeah I was read this time
last year the you released was Daniel of
last year didn't release part 1 X what
did you anticipate it was gonna take
that long to get the second one to get
this right I'm in the first half to two
years yeah so the second half took just
one year so it's much faster yeah what
did you for fast now did you think that
was going to happen though when you were
creating it no way that we're gonna do
it all in one piece but we decided this
way because you want to do this bigger
game and it's awesome the second half is
bigger even and and crazier and really
happy with how it's turning out we're
also doing a massive chalice just be you
come fine on them thinking about other
things that are no no secret stuff some
other surprises and everything else yeah
we're gonna I don't know if we're gonna
yeah who knows when that will be
finished but we're starting right now
the grim is done we're putting the team
on yeah David did you guys have so many
different projects happening at any one
time between these like your remastering
old games you are working on like the
smaller stuff you also have like all
that and is a top fine presents
obviously gang beasts was involved yeah
and that sort of stuff is anything new
coming at ya and then basford uh we have
been helping out us mostly Greg over
there hiding in the pee in the corners
doing double fine presents working is no
one there
I like all it's like the six foot tall
rabbit over there you don't see him oh
my god what if it turns out that he was
just an imaginary rabbit that no one
else can see yeah I'm I don't know my
gosh um yeah I've been working with
boneless on crime tempo Nostrum can't
forget boneless gang beasts and by
working with them I mean they're working
and making the guy going yeah like that
game and yeah we published a bunch of
games under that we're going to be doing
more that this year because it's just
you know way to kind of like use some of
the stuff we've learned over the years
to help out indy's who have not done
that yet or just want more exposure to
us what's it like working in the sort of
modern video game production world where
there are so many different like options
for for releasing games like obviously
through Kickstarter you guys have has
the broken age stuff you guys had a
little bit of backlash with green light
last year or early access with space
base and which was people thought might
have been a bigger game but then ended
up sort of you guys finished early
finished it earlier on and what's it
been like messing around with these
different like ways of releasing games
where do you think like the strong ones
are what do you think like the ones that
maybe won't work out I mean that's
what's been great about having we've
been doing multiple smaller project so
we could try out like we try to free to
play game with middle manager and we did
you know you know mobile and we can try
kick-started game we done investor based
games just differ funding a different
gameplay different platforms so we can
try all these different different
mediums and they have been a lot of them
have been a lot of fun obviously the
favour was that Kickstarter experience
and just not just getting all that money
but getting that kind of community
involvement in the games and they do
feel really knew obviously and some of
them like they're new and something
we're pretty suspicious of them like you
were suspicious of Kickstarter there ya
go what is free money are you getting
almost every money and I you know I'm
looking forward to like actually
finishing that game so you'd be like
well this is what you get further yeah
all that free money now felt like the
project that actually legitimized
Kickstarter and a lot of people's eyes
as well because it was sort of a oh this
is like a real thing that a real company
is probably going to put it yeah and I
think that's an interesting thing to
uh it's it's a great way to fund a
project because you're working for the
fans which you are always anyway but
there's no one there's no like middleman
between you there's no one you know
offering you have someone funding a
project they've risked the money and
they want to hear all wide you're not
gonna lose their money and so you spend
a lot of time talking about how this is
going to make a bunch of money for you
instead of talking to like the fans what
they want and when something's
crowdfunded it's like they've paid you
and so now you're just doing like how
can I make this game really good for you
and it's more natural conversation so
love do more of that in the future in
some form excellent well one of the
things that fans wanted was grim
fandango available on modern platforms
and now they can go and play it at Grim
Fandango what's the official title is it
like a video romantic remastered
remaster we might you didn't got in the
resident evil relative calling if we
master which knows resident evil HD
remaster did you know that that's
actually the proper title according to
wikipedia not according to gamespot
though we actually put it in as remaster
as we were like f you this is why you
guys should have called it a good thing
to do you guys because you changed you
call us all powerful j's pub nothing is
more powerful than internet games
journalism we're doing all right folks
you're doing all right